it's been over a year since i got my 15
000
mac pro and i can officially see that
apple screwed the pros
again and i don't think they even care
to be honest i think that they gave up
on the mac pro
less than a year after its release and
then this video i'll let you know how
and why
and to add to that yes i do think that
even on the mac pro is a very powerful
and capable machine
it's officially a failure and it's very
hard for me to recommend it to people
who i consult for
that actually need the performance only
it can offer on a mac
and they can afford to drop 10 to 20 000
on a machine now before i jump into the
three biggest reasons why it failed
why you should be careful buying one and
what you should buy instead if you need
a powerful machine
let's touch on apple's previous failure
the trash can
everybody was shocked when apple showed
off the mac pro cylinder
and phil schiller proudly boasted on
their achievements and innovation
can't innovate anymore my ass
a lot of people including me were very
skeptical of the price points and design
but apple tried to assure people that
they would have upgrades as the graphics
cards could be swapped
out to newer models and the cpu was
socketed and the thermal core design
was groundbreaking allowing the pro to
run cool and silent
and that external expansion was the
future
with that a fair bit of pros ended up
giving it a shot
including a much younger me seven years
ago when i was just a few years into my
photography and filmmaking career
i was working a basic full-time job and
building up my business on the side
and i ended up taking out a six thousand
dollar loan to
buy myself the black cylinder which back
then was a much bigger chunk of my
income
than this 15 000 mac pro is now and you
know what
it wasn't a mistake paired with final
cut pro it allowed me to edit faster
than my custom pc
that cost less and had way better specs
and it ended up being a fantastic
investment for my growing business
and it made me money while it did
eventually fail because
apple didn't ever upgrade it even five
years later
the first few years it was very very
powerful and although apple later
admitted its mistakes and now went back
to a fully upgradable design
i'm not sure it actually matters and
i'll explain why fast forward six years
and on the surface
apple gave us everything we asked for we
had this gorgeous
all aluminum cheese graders design we
had tons of ram and ssd capacity
crazy cpus and a bunch of pci slots so
we could upgrade as we please
and even use third-party parts and
accessories instead of being locked in
and yes we even had 700 wheels i was
all about this pro machine for a few
reasons
first off my previous mac pro was a
great investment but it was all locked
down so it didn't last long term
but this one promised to fix all of
those issues
we had all the ports and support for
easy third party upgrades
it reminded me of the much love cheese
grater mac pro that many people still
use today
but this mac pro solved the biggest
issue people had with that one
for example having a 1400 watt power
supply so it can handle
anything that you want to throw at it in
the future which is why
that base price costs so much and
finally the pure performance of the
system
smoked anything else that was out there
at the end of last year
not only was the cpu performance a good
step up from the other max
but the graphics performance was
absolutely off the charts
and this is before the driver
optimizations for the vega 2 that made
it even better
for example it exported red footage in
almost half the time than my imac pro
and pro vs raw files in a third of the
time which was
insane now of course that is just
exporting
but when it came to actual playback
performance it killed the other max
being the only machine
that can handle c200 raw files in
multicam it was also the only computer i
have ever seen
that could export this footage in real
time
with optimize software now i work mostly
with video but this machine was an
absolute beast for photo editing being
two to three times faster than my other
macs
now you might say that this should be
the case because it's so expensive and
you're right
but it actually provided a good value
because not only was it faster than the
high-end imac pro
but it was actually cheaper than one
even when you factor in
buying a display and other extras that
you need and you can also upgrade it as
you please
as you can see i was very bullish on
this machine but
not everybody was people had a few
issues right off the bat
first of course the price was
astronomical with a base price of six
thousand dollars
which included an acor processor 32 gigs
of ram 256 gigs of ssd and an rx 580
based graphics card
which was embarrassing especially
because you can get that level of
performance
for half the price in an imac at the
time and that also includes a 5k display
a keyboard and mouse and also decent
speakers
i called apple out on their base price
in a video showing that the mac pros
have always had a price of about three
thousand dollars base when you adjust
for inflation until this machine came
out
at six thousand dollars but even then
you had to spend about
ten 000 to make it a decent value so it
became unaffordable for most small
business owners and freelancers
what people were really concerned about
was a cpu socket being one that would be
outdated quickly
possibly never having an upgrade path
with new cpus and the fact that the pci
slots were pci express 3
which was the same tech back in the 2013
trashcan
not pci express 4 which was already on
the market but a year later
these things haven't really made an
impact on the machine
or even the competition what made the
mac pro a failure was apple
themselves and here's how now the most
obvious and painful one is apple silicon
which i'll talk about in just a bit
but there are two more things that i've
really heard it which i want to cover
first the first is the lack of
additional parts or upgrades
a few months before the mac pro's
release amd put out their new 5700 xt
now i was expecting apple to work with
amd and to offer this card but
nope it was either the weak base 580 or
spending another 2
400 for a decent usable graphics card
the vega 2. now surely apple would offer
it soon after since they work directly
with amd
and they know ahead of time which gpus
are in the pipeline but nope
it took another six months after amd
publicly announced this card
for apple's version to be released which
is probably a year or more after apple
knew of that gpu
and that is just the start as you know
the mac pro can use third-party graphics
cards so why not just buy a 5700 xt and
use it
well we did but the performance was
really really lacking
coming in slower than the base gpu or
even a 2500
imac that's because apple wasn't
updating the drivers for the graphics
card and only had a buggy first release
available for close to eight months
which is crazy now if you don't already
know apple has taken over
all control over gpu drivers so amd
can't simply release their own optimized
ones which is also why you can no longer
use nvidia graphics cards
in newer versions of mac os and because
of their faulty driver
if you had one display connected the
performance tanked
but if you had two displays connected to
the two ports that didn't flake out out
of the four
ports you could get almost twice the
performance now i understand that they
want more control over the user
experience and to focus on metal
optimizations
but when it takes apple eight months for
them to fix a simple bug in the driver
and they only do so when they release
their version of that graphics card
that is a huge you know what finger to
the pro users
who are buying a 6 000 machine not only
that
but their version of the 5700 xt ends up
performing on average about 25
better than buying a much cheaper
third-party card
where the same card under windows is far
more powerful and that is using opencl
which always scores lower than metal but
it gets
worse the w5700 that apple wants you to
buy
shipped with its own driver issues
causing consistent crashes and many
popular pro
apps and apple promised a fix back in
august
but it's been seven months and people
are still having the same
issue and amd even stated that it is an
issue with apple's drivers that they
can't
fix and apple needs to fix it and it's
been almost a year
since that graphics card launched and
lastly for graphics card
amd's powerful new 6000 series of
graphics cards that released four months
ago are still
not compatible with the mac pro with
users waiting on
each and each macos beta release to
hopefully get support
or for apple to release their version of
the card now i don't know about you
but this isn't what i was expecting when
i got this machine a year ago
sure it may have tons of ports for
upgrades but if apple is keeping
everything so locked down
and not working on bug fixes what is the
point for this machine
to be upgradable we also had a recent
report that amd may repurpose its apple
exclusive gpus into cryptocurrency
mining units
which makes it sound like apple may be
ditching amd altogether and moving
completely to its own graphics ships
and that's the only thing that can
explain why they are so behind on driver
updates
and new parts for their super expensive
pro
custom machine and now we know that
apple is working on a new mac pro that
will be about half the size and use
apple's cpus and gpus but deem did a
video on this and it will be an
absolute decent performance with really
good optimization
and most likely a lower price as well
bringing us back down to that starting
price of all the previous mac pros
once adjusted for inflation so with all
of that it seems like apple almost gave
up on the mac pro less than a year after
launch
and we know it's because apple silicon
macs are the future
even with the weakest mac mini which i
compared to this 50 000 mac pro
where it stood up to you and even beat
out the mac pro in many real world tests
apple knows that their own chips are the
future of max
and i think that is why they haven't
really been focusing on this mac pro
and thanks to our tests and comparisons
a lot of you guys know this as well
which is probably why i haven't been
able to sell my mac pro for over two
months now
even though it's priced at close to half
off nobody wants to buy it
and i don't blame them so what should
you buy if you need a powerful machine
and you can't wait for a new m1x mac
or apple silicon mac pro well if you're
looking for a new machine i think that
the 5k imac with the acor processor and
whichever graphics you need is a great
bang for the buck
or even better if you can find a used
imac
pro at a deep deep discount i think the
prices will stay
fairly well on those since they've
already been dropping so much
as soon as they've discontinued these
and of course they are not going to be
making
any new ones so that's going to keep the
value up now if you do
need pci slots or a bunch of gpu power
and you want to buy a mac pro
try to find a discounted used one like
mine instead of dropping 15 000 on a new
one
and then when you're ready to replace it
you will lose a lot less money
overall my question is why would apple
release this mac pro if they knew that
it would get slaughtered so
quickly after its release and by apple
itself
due to new cheaper faster machines and
then them basically seemingly giving up
working on it to me it is a huge bummer
and even though it still performs great
in many tasks
i can't help feel that even though apple
finally made another modular pro machine
it doesn't really matter now and apple
once again screwed the pros
but let me know your thoughts down below
is the mac pro still worth it
or should i have never been released
until apple was ready with their own
chips
go ahead and check out my comparison
with the m1 mac mini right over there
and click above to subscribe if you guys
want to see more videos like this one
this max and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
video